empezó el mundial de fútbol de Qatar
2022 envuelto en críticas por las
violaciones de doha de los Derechos
Humanos en el partido de apertura por
primera vez el equipo visitante Ecuador
ganó a la selección anfitriona Qatar
Turquía mató a 15 personas de las
fuerzas kurdas y sirias en un bombardeo
en el kurdistán de iraquísima según el
gobierno Turco los ataques fueron en
represalia al atentado bomba de Estambul
de la semana pasada que mató a seis
personas
en Estados Unidos su nombre de 22 años
mató a cinco personas e hirió a 25 en un
club lgbt en Colorado en la noche de la
memoria trumps el agresor que perpetró
el ataque con un rifle está bajo
custodia policial
Buenas noches Bienvenidos a las noticias
de Franz 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
mateu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
empezó el mundial de Qatar 2022 rodeado
de críticas por las violaciones de los
derechos humanos de doja y por primera
vez la seleccionan anfitriona perdió el
partido de apertura Ecuador venció 2 a 0
a Qatar y ahora lidera su grupo nuestra
enviada especial al mundial Natalia Ruiz
con más información
este lunes hoy nos esperan a tres
partidos aquí en acatar con la entrada
Elisa del grupo B Inglaterra abrirá este
baile ante Irán los hogares que de hecho
no podrán contar con walker en defensa
afuera por el lesión al menos en este
partido y también pues el entrenador
inglés se dijo Jesús jugadores van a
ponerse de rodillas antes del comienzo
de ese partido en nombre de la inclusión
y contra el racismo el segundo partido
será la entrada Elisa en realidad de los
otros dos equipos del grupo a junto con
Qatar y Ecuador será un duelo entre
senegal y Países Bajos en senegal que no
contará esta vez con su estrella sadio
humanes que está fuera de este mundial
por lesión también lesionado también
Memphis depay el delantero estrella
Igualmente de los Países Bajos pero
tendrá por supuesto a banda
de este equipo y el tercer duelo de este
día pues es una Duelo anglosajón entre
los Estados Unidos y gales Estados
Unidos que regresa al mundial después de
8 años y por supuesto pues hay gales que
tendrá a su estrella Gareth Bale
y precisamente en algunos países como
Francia o Alemania decenas de activistas
protestaron por las violaciones de
derechos humanos de Qatar a pesar de que
el mundial de fútbol ya fue inaugurado
con bombo y platillo este domingo
recordemos que según de Guardian
6.500 personas murieron levantando la
infraestructura de la competición doha
niega las acusaciones y hasta invitó a
un grupo de inmigrantes que trabajaron
en la construcción de los estadios al
partido de apertura
empezó el mundial de fútbol en Qatar y
los activistas sus acciones en contra
del evento denunciaron de nuevo las
violaciones de Derechos Humanos a los
trabajadores inmigrantes que ayudaron a
que las obras para el encuentro de la
FIFA estuvieran listas
me pregunto Cómo podemos jugar al fútbol
e ignorar el cambio climático los
migrantes que murieron construyendo los
estadios la gente que vive en la miseria
en Qatar como podemos ignorar todo esto
para que Durante un mes podamos vivir en
la película del mundial como si no
pasara nada
en Berlín frente a la puerta de
brandeburgo con tumbas simuladas
activistas recordaron a los inmigrantes
muertos
encontraste en el estadio de doha en el
juego inaugural de Qatar contra Ecuador
un grupo de inmigrantes estaba invitado
para ver el partido y dijo estar feliz
de estar en la copa mundo
llevo dos años aquí trabajando en la
construcción y terminando los estadios y
ahora Estamos aquí para disfrutar la
copas
porque todo está hecho la construcción
está terminada ahora Estamos aquí para
disfrutar de nuestro sudor
Qatar que también ha sido acusado por la
persecución de las personas lgbtiq más
ha dicho que es un país acogedor que no
discrimina a las personas y ha negado
las acusaciones de abuso a los
trabajadores
este domingo el ejército de Turquía
bombardeo a las fuerzas curvas del norte
de si e Irak los cazas turcos mataron al
menos a 15 personas e hirieron a 31
según el observatorio sirio de Derechos
Humanos el gobierno de erdogan presenta
la operación como una represalia al
ataque bomba de Estambul de la semana
pasada que atribuye a las milicias
kurdas de Siria sin embargo los grupos
kurdos rechazan la autoría del atentado
en estas imágenes se ven los bombardeos
aéreos del ejército Turco en el marco de
su operación bautizada Las garras de la
espada y lanzada en el norte de Irak y
Siria unas zonas que ankara sospecha son
las bases de las fuerzas curvas
consideradas como terroristas por el
gobierno Turco antes de la ofensiva el
Ministerio de defensa tuiteó
ha llegado la hora de la verdad los
sinvergüenzas tendrán que rendir cuentas
por sus ataques traicioneros En
referencia al atentado del 13 de
noviembre que dejó un saldo de seis
muertos e hirió a 81 personas en el
corazón de Estambul las autoridades
turcas habían inmediatamente señalado al
partido de los trabajadores del
kurdistán pkk y el yepegué una milicia
curva activa en Siria como responsables
pero el pkk y el yepegué negaron
cualquier implicación en el ataque estos
kurdos de Siria se manifestaron el
domingo Viven cerca del lugar de las
explosiones
bombardearon la central eléctrica cinco
veces está completamente destruida no
queda nada nos quedamos para sacar a los
heridos de debajo de los escombros
cuando de repente un avión no sobrevoló
y tuvimos que huir
de momento la ofensiva lanzada el sábado
por la noche Solo consiste en una
operación aérea pero Turquía lleva
varios meses amenazando con enviar
tropas a Siria hasta ahora ankara no ha
conseguido la luz verde de Rusia e Irán
Aliados del régimen sirio y entre
críticas Egipto puso punto final a la
Cumbre del clima número 27 en charmers
el texto final de este encuentro logró
Establecer un fondo de compensación para
países empobrecidos golpeados por
desastres climáticos pero no habla de
nueva reducciones de emisiones
contaminantes para lograr los objetivos
a final de siglo
fue una de las cumbres del clima más
largas de la historia después de 12 días
más uno de prórroga en medio de
negociaciones multitudinarias El acuerdo
de la co-27 en charmershake dejó una
sensación de insatisfacción para la
Unión Europea que previamente había
amenazado con retirarse de las
conversaciones si no se acordaban
mejores compromisos sobre emisiones el
texto se quedó corto ya que no adoptó un
lenguaje fuerte para la mitigación de
emisiones contaminantes la Unión Europea
vino para que se adoptara un lenguaje
fuerte estamos decepcionados de que esto
no se lograra lo que tenemos en frente a
nosotros no es un paso adelante
suficiente para las personas en el
planeta no trae suficientes esfuerzos
adicionales de los principales emisores
aumentar y acelerar sus recortes de
emisiones Y es que para varios líderes
se trata de un retroceso frente al
acuerdo de Glasgow habla de una
reducción rápida de las emisiones pero
no tiene nuevas ambiciones de reducción
de gases de efecto invernadero la co27
concluyó con muchas tareas y poco tiempo
ya estamos a mitad de camino el acuerdo
de París y la fecha límite de 2030
necesitamos todas las manos puestas en
la obra para impulsar la justicia y la
ambición sin embargo el texto final sí
dejó una victoria para algunos países en
Vía de desarrollo la creación de un
fondo específico que financiará los
países más empobrecidos por las pérdidas
y daños causados por el cambio climático
Estoy muy emocionado muy muy emocionado
Este es un resultado muy positivo para
1300 millones de africanos según
expertos suponiendo que se cumplan Los
acuerdos en su totalidad El mundo
estaría encaminado a los 2,4 grados
centígrados para finales de siglo pero
al ritmo actual el planeta estaría
llegando a los catastróficos 2,8 grados
centígrados muy por encima del objetivo
de los 1,5 grados la siguiente Cumbre
será en emiratos árabes Unidos gran
productor de combustibles fósiles
en Estados Unidos ayer por la noche un
hombre de 22 años mató a cinco personas
e hirió a otras 25 en un bar lgbt y
cumas en Colorado Springs el agresor que
ya se encuentra bajo custodia policial
abrió fuego con un rifle en el club q
donde se conmemoraba la noche de la
memoria transms Precisamente en recuerdo
de las personas trans asesinadas en
ataques violentos
[Música]
Era una noche festiva en el club q Un
refugio para la comunidad lgbt de
Colorado Springs estaban conmemorando el
20 de noviembre Día del Recuerdo
transgénero cuando cada año se hace un
homenaje a las personas trans asesinadas
en plena fiesta irrumpió una persona
armada y disparó
cuando salí había cuerpos en el piso
había vidrios rotos vasos rotos gente
llorando
[Aplausos]
el sospechoso fue identificado como
Anderson leald de 22 años dos personas
lo redujeron y evitaron que pudiera
continuar matando el club q los llamó
héroes en un comunicado y así lo vivió
uno de sus camareros
mi primer pensamiento en lo que no puedo
dejar de pensar es en las imágenes de la
noche de los cuerpos de la sangre de los
vidrios rotos de la carnicería y los
escombros y ver un lugar seguro
convertido en una zona de guerra
el ataque más mortal después del 11 de
septiembre de 2021 fue en 2016 en una
discoteca lgbti de Orlando cuando 49
personas fueron asesinadas según
estadísticas oficiales Estados Unidos
vive un resurgimiento de ataques contra
personas transgénero el presidente Joe
biden se solidarizó y debemos eliminar
las desigualdades que contribuyen a la
violencia contra las personas lgbtq y
más no podemos tolerar el odio en el
debate los ataques contra personas lgbti
pero también el uso de armas Estados
Unidos ha vivido 600 un tiroteos en lo
que va de año en un país que tiene más
armas que habitantes y en el que 49.000
personas murieron por heridas de bala en
2021 una cifra récord en Argentina el
presidente Alberto Fernández decretó
tres días de luto nacional por la muerte
de un símbolo de la resistencia contra
La dictadura A los 93 años de edad murió
hebe de bonafini la presidenta de la
asociación madres de la Plaza de Mayo
quien combatió el régimen de Jorge
Videla tras la desaparición de sus dos
hijos nuestro corresponsal en Buenos
Aires natalio cossoy no repasa la figura
de bonafini pensemos una señora que a
sus 49 años en el año 77 era ama de casa
en la provincia de Buenos Aires y se
encontró con la realidad de que la
dictadura había secuestrado y hecho
desaparecer a sus dos hijos varones a
partir de Entonces se ju con otras
mujeres en su misma situación y conformó
lo que fue Madres de Plaza de Mayo con
esas primeras marchas en la Plaza de
Mayo muy muy valientes en pedido en
pedido por el paradero de sus hijos se
consolidó como una figura importante de
los Derechos Humanos en el país también
a nivel mundial luego también empezó a
tomar posiciones a veces un poco más
radicales profundamente ante
imperialistas anti neoliberales de
defensa muchas veces de regímenes
cuestionados en la región regímenes de
izquierda y eso ha generado que su
figura se haya vuelto una figura muchas
veces criticada en el país a la vez que
respetada yo creo que conviven esas dos
eves de bonafina en el recuerdo de
Argentina pero no se puede negar que ha
sido una figura central en la historia
de Argentina de los últimos 45 años y
este fin de semana en antigua Guatemala
se llevó a cabo un festival de flores
que atrajo a más de 400.000 personas un
homenaje a la industria floricultora de
esta ciudad declarada patrimonio de la
humanidad por la UNESCO
la víspera del festival de las Flores es
el momento para vestir esta ciudad de
Centroamérica Lupita Toledo es una de
las floristas más experimentadas por
haber sido la primera ganadora de este
evento que convoca a 2.000 artistas la
emoción de trabajar en las noches es
para que mañana amanezca que se inaugura
el festival
amanezca todo adornado y que todos
nuestros visitantes todas las personas
cuando Despierten verdad lo primero que
van a ver es la belleza de las flores en
las fachadas en las calles según la
asociación de exportadores de Guatemala
las flores aseguran el trabajo
permanente de 15.000 personas al año de
las cuales el 80% son mujeres en esta
edición Lupita escogió rendir un
homenaje a los vestidos icónicos de las
indígenas guatemaltecas realmente yo las
admiro a ellos las mujeres indígenas son
increíblemente creativas
con una belleza hacen bellezas con sus
manos son excelentes artesanas para
amanecer Sí ya veo este Qué lindo llegó
el día anhelado por los floristas y con
este el aroma de Las Rosas como abejas
con el polen más de 400.000 turistas se
ven atraídos por los arreglos florales
el tema de esta edición es el de las
rosas perpetuas bueno el Antiguo es
conocida románticamente como la ciudad
de Las perpetuas Rosas ha sido mucha
Inspiración de muchos poetas muchos
escritores incluso la historia del
Principito se cree que acá era el
asteroide b612 los artistas compiten por
ganarse el premio del arreglo floral más
original y pues los jueces lo que ven es
un poquito composición originalidad me
encanta por ejemplo esta esta Barbie que
tiene el traje típico de Guatemala y
tiene el café abrazado podría ser que
esto sea muy llamativo para jueces a la
hora de calificar la industria de las
Flores deja una ganancia de 120 millones
de dólares un motivo de orgullo para
Guatemala conocido como el país de la
eterna Primavera
Muchísimas gracias por su atención sigan
con más información en francés 24 y
24.com
[Música]